this fool was the first to do so many
things he would name it something but he
wasn't thinking it would catch on so he
has some dumbass names out there like
what and then people go like why is it
named that oh yeah I wondered he's like
I don't know
[Music]
welcome everyone to another amazing
episode of careful boys today we have
with us Mr Steve Toronto
[Applause]
Legends Legends there's a lot of people
out there who know who Steve Toronto is
and uh a lot of people don't mostly
people don't so let's go ahead and uh
get you equated with him Steve is a
legend in the martial arts tricking
Community we should put the footage up
while you're saying this introducing
[Laughter]
so Steve uh he's a member of Quest Crew
he's also uh when I met him I had no
clue that he was the same guy I used to
watch on ESPN when I was a kid uh
competing on these uh what was it that
you were on uh US Open uh karate wow for
Paul Mitchell yeah Paul Mitchell was
yeah so he's kind of like responsible
for the the way that tricking is today
like there's a there's a he is
responsible yeah not kind of shoulders
yeah he is he is responsible yeah yeah
he's not gonna ever say it so that's why
I'm saying it now or else you'll never
hear it that's why we're saying it yeah
I knew if Steve Toronto maybe even since
I was
maybe in high school so I oh [__] I
don't know what came first but there was
a video that like Steve was like
teaching a break dancing tutorial
and it goes like this
and then I think he goes like uh this is
how you do a Gainer
can you just see this guy with this
crazy ass box
I think so I
if it's the one that I'm thinking about
yeah that's freaking crazy and then you
don't remember doing this I don't know
about those
that was awkward that was awkward and I
used to watch this
oh dude I think it was that
Scotty yeah but I've seen this
a flash kick not a gator I mean that's
the same [__] anyway actually this
right okay I mean a flash kick is a
Gainer with a kick right yeah yeah
that's pretty much the same shirt
then I remember seeing uh Paul Mitchell
stuff because I would geek out over
those things yeah yeah Arnold trying me
like he's like Legend too
yeah we're like [__] trance music and
[__]
[__] that's [__] crazy yeah Arnold
was my coach back today but I remember
yeah video with him that's how I first
saw you guys yeah Arnold Sean looks like
YouTube put together
yeah it was like uh old JK video I was
like what the heck and you guys were all
talking talking yeah he was he uh he
watched our stuff back when we used to
still shoot on like super like ghetto
cameras and then uh he invited us over
to his house to watch that UFC and then
that was like the first time I think me
and Joe saw like real celebrity or
celebrities and but the funniest thing
was Donald Trump he was taking like
Wesley Snipes up to his computer to show
him our [__] and then we're just like oh
my God
I don't know
Lawrence Fishburne was there
Bill cause
she would tell ageo
Michael Jai why was there that's crazy
we were just like
oh [__] this is [__] crazy
that's pretty wild yeah if I don't know
who's your coach yeah he coached me
um when I was a junior so like 16 to 17.
yeah
yeah yeah and he you know that he did
those all those Impressions and stuff
while we were training too so you'd be
talking like an accent like like the
Kung Fu Master dude yeah yeah yeah and
he's just tell me you tied go again
go again and then I just throw up and
then be like all right that's enough
how did you get into all this stuff like
uh martial arts yeah but like at a high
level oh a high level um I I was on a
demo team when at my local school for a
while and then that kind of opened it up
to like tournaments and scene was like
well you can do all these cool routines
and like flips I wasn't into that before
yeah and we just started learning single
moves and eventually I was doing a whole
bunch of junior tournaments that paid
money so I could actually travel around
so like I just worked to go compete and
then I started from martial arts yeah
yeah that came first and then then you
then breaking came after because it was
so easy
[Laughter]
all the best B boys went there
they would bring cameras and kind of
like rehearse routines and over the
shoulder when he falls and do whatever
like just like it was such a like I
think it was such a trip to be there
back in the day because it's the first
time you see like a dude breaking some
guy doing flips a guy with a big ass bow
staff and then Arnold in the corner
kicking a bag and it's so loud yeah and
then it'd be like wow this is like a
paradise and then I saw this dude doing
some crazy flip my one of my first times
there and I went up to him and I was
like Hey how do you do that and he goes
oh you should ask that guy
I don't remember that
no yeah that was that was pretty well
but I knew him through zanga so zanga
that's where Olympics remembered it's
always it's so cool to see like the
birth of culture you know now you got
Jam right kind of like a Consolidated
place right right but like before then
like even in Fitness and stuff there's
like
like almost the culture like precedes
what are the brands and stuff of today
and it's cool that you guys had so much
passion that you guys would go to just
the random community college and that
was like the birth of that cult dude
yeah and it's still going today right
they still do sessions there yeah they
still do open sessions what's a
different crowd it's a different vibe
like the old La Valley was very like uh
like a little bunker hanger it's all
dirty and the lighting was bad so I just
got a little bit more rotten and you had
all these really dope professionals like
all of the the cool like stunt people
were working there all the best view was
you know so it was just a good
environment to be around but yeah now
there's no incentive it's just passion
based but I think now it's like oh he
did he was famous because of this so
there's like it's like a little bit
different you would catch a lot of
people that were just humbling doing
their own thing like there was just one
really old uh white guy who would climb
a he was like an ex Olympian or
something we saw that that was a little
crew yeah yeah they had they had
groupies too they always come through
with Grandma group
they're like 80 years old and they would
climb and go to the top in their Grandma
group you could just watch and it was
like he was doing it just to for Fitness
huh like yeah I think they used to do
some of it uh competitively and they've
just been doing this consistently for
forever so they're still alive because
they were old when we went there I was
like damn these 80 year olds are just
climbing to the top with just arms if
that dude's still alive then that's
another world record you know what's
crazy so uh boys just stuck at the top
of the road
get back down
so before uh the crazy thing is that uh
uh he was already dancing by the time
that I met him but I didn't really know
that and then uh there was a team that I
joined called six step and then they
asked me to be in a show because he
couldn't do it and I didn't really know
him and they were like yeah this Steve
Toronto guy can't make it because he's
competing with martial arts so can you
take his place so I took his place in
the show and I had his name tag
basically because yeah
and then uh and I hadn't even worked
with him yet and I was just like oh yeah
that guy couldn't go and then when I
finally met him he was like Hey you owe
me money for that pass
okay
you're like I'm an [__] it's like 25
bucks to like preset you yeah position
on there so you guys are on six steps
together first yeah yeah yeah that was
wild too because like one day it was a
completely different team and then like
two weeks later I came back and then it
was like all the guys that are currently
on Quest yeah so this joke were there I
was like he didn't know Hawk he didn't
know heiress or nothing and then when he
got back from his trip all of us were on
the team and this is like 2005.
yeah and he was like who are these new
dudes and why are they so cool honestly
knocking away I was feeling pretty cool
this is so this is crazy uh how did I
want to know how air this is just me
personally how did Eris get in the group
because heiress used to date Geo's
sister-in-law
like there's if you go to Jill's mom's
house there's pictures of Eris from high
school
wait who's her sister-in-law
uh her name's Cloud Claudia
because that's what in the beginning
when Quest versus I got David ABDC
game events and then Jill would see
Harrison but hey and they're like
hugging I'm like who the [__]
each other
like early high school because I don't I
don't think I know her
it's not crazy like just a small it is
yeah but he was always there next time I
go I'll take a picture please so they're
like prom pictures yeah prom pictures
what like that yeah yeah I'm like [__]
up that does not surprise me
yeah that's funny that was because
heiress was in every people crew I was
in since I was 17. and I just everything
we did he always like came along and did
it too yeah there's no rules in dance
about being in different groups like
yeah
[Laughter]
failed and then we started another one
see that's okay yeah we didn't you gotta
finish one before you
can't be in all of them at the same
Joe's a man of principle dude he doesn't
[__] around but like you know what's
what I wanted you to explain Steve is
like what happened with you and martial
arts that gave birth to like the form of
tricking that you brought around the
world oh well I know what Korea had a
lot to do with it when you went for to
like teach Korea yeah I think at the
start of tricking there weren't there
wasn't that many moves yet so that it
was just like tricks so once uh like my
generation of uh like competition
started coming in and the internet
started coming around then we just
started like trying to add more and more
and more what year was it like I think
uh I think around like 2001 ish what
would you say is like the standard set
of tricks that you could learn at like a
martial arts school and then what were
the other tricks above that kind of
evolved into something else uh well I
mean originally they had like a 540
which is like a insect resin kick
landing on her kicking leg you see it
all the time in dance there's butterfly
twist but I was like oh yeah I got back
tuck or Flash kick
um what about the Van Damme one oh
they're pop 360. that's that's like yeah
all that's all that stuff was was there
and then I think once we started getting
to like 720s like double spinning and
then doing like harder variations of
that then that started getting like
one-ups doing multiple kicks during
different spins and like starting to
inverted tricks like side swipes like
like all once it started getting
inverted and then extra spins then there
it just opened up a whole bunch of
different animal navigations yeah it was
like based in martial arts but then also
bringing in other elements you know what
I like is that this fool was the first
to do so many things he would name it
something but he wasn't thinking it
would catch on so he has some dumbass
names out there like what and then
people go like why is it named that oh
yeah I wonder like how he's like I don't
know
which one did you name uh Snappy swipe
like Snap that's another Arnold one
though like uh it's a crazy ass move too
yeah that one's like a move called
Corkscrew Corkscrew yeah box cutter box
cutter that yeah box cutter there's no
way to Pat and move there's the terada
flash you guys know what the Toronto wow
what's that well I mean you like kicked
four times yeah you know that oh [__] it
looks resurfaced now like a lot of
people are doing it now again but like
when you punch off and then you just do
switching flashes oh my God so I did
first want to do like multiple switches
like three three or more oh is that what
that is you can't you can't copyright
moves like the way you can copyright a
song or whatever no I don't think so
it's not not as of right now no it's
it's hard huh you can't even copy you
can't even trademark an entire like
eight minute choreography so yeah like
so someone else could just do it that's
not true Galen hooks actually did a
whole legal battle with a copyright she
did regiment for her choreography piece
and she actually won the case
yeah so like it's like a sec it has to
be like a segment of moves and you have
to prove that it was like the sequences
the sequences weren't just that she
actually won wow damn I didn't know that
dang that'll be interesting because then
I think the the stuff about innovators
is oftentimes like it's like a pyramid
right you got the innovator and then
like you have like the top creators that
know how to translate that to the public
or whatever and then they get they get
known as the guys that are like doing
the move but they actually like learned
it from the innovator and every I think
industry is shaped this way we're like
the ones that invent things they
actually don't translate it to the
public the way that the people in the
middle track that's true yeah yeah it's
like most most things that is what
happened like most art most films all
that stuff like the best like the
directors director would be like no one
likes that lame [__] yeah some guy you
never heard of yeah but then the
director's all cream for them that's
like
anime perfect blue when they took all
the [__] from perfect blue and all these
movies do it now
but back to you back to Steve Toronto
the cool thing about you what about
Korea all your shit's on video
yeah yeah at this at the start it was
like the brink of Internet okay so yeah
you had to download his clip took
forever
oh yeah like I was uh one of the first
Americans to like go out there
um so before before then did they view
you as America my view as a dirty
Japanese
[Laughter]
your fourth gen Japanese American yeah
yeah fourth chance wow American dude
yeah
dude but he went out there and you
taught them martial arts tricking
specifically yeah I just did when
and did a whole bunch of demos and at
like the cookie one which is the uh
Taekwondo World Headquarters I went to
different universities trained with them
uh did like new spots how to speak
Korean
yeah
they told you what to say yeah hey so
pretty much pretty much this is the
whitest dude trying to speak Korean that
you've never heard it before so yeah
yeah it did all those and then um they
just pretty much took whatever I showed
and then
uh trained it up like the Koreans do
yeah you know then they just expanded on
because I remember you said that the
next time you like went back or saw them
they were like a different level well
yeah that's kind of how it went because
like like whenever the Americans would
go to a different place
um they you know there wasn't that much
footage back then so whatever they would
see they would just practice and
practice and practice that so like in
Europe and in Korea so whatever they saw
I was like the foundation yeah in uh
Korea for for like tricking and then I
still talked to all those guys like the
Korean Tigers dude Mitchell he's like
really big he's a Red Bull I thought I
was I thought it was cool I was trying
to relate to this dude when I met him
I'm like yo check this clip out and it
was Korean Tigers these guys that were
and he's like oh yeah I know those guys
but like he was he didn't tell me until
way later that they do that because of
him they're my students
through any stunt group of people that
I've hung around they always bring up
your name at some point really yeah
because you're [__] Legend dude you
don't know that you don't know that
you're a legend yeah no he's he's so
[__] humble they always bring his
name up and I always heard this name
Steve Toronto Steve and then you have to
have a moment of silence and [__] yeah
and we all we all take time it's
probably they're probably younger guys
though not all I don't know I don't know
if they're younger
like Gemma you know Gemma oh Gemma yeah
she talked about you a bunch and I was
like I've heard this name from my friend
Ryan because Ryan always brings you up
yeah and everyone like starts talking
about how cool you are and all the moves
you innovated and I'm like holy [__] I
had no [__] idea we have a video with
Gemma Gemma new win I kicked her and
then she was a backflip after watch you
kick her dude because we were teaching
women self-defense
it was no joke it was a women's
self-defense course and we just ended up
beating up all the girls that's [__]
awesome yeah
[Laughter]
with her first things yeah yeah actually
she competed before I did she was a
little ass kid I I have videos of her
competing when she's like I don't know
how how old she was but she was like two
feet tall
but yeah yeah so I joined the circuit
that she was doing okay um then we
trained for a little bit together too
even though she's like from Virginia I
think but yeah you know it's like
sometimes we meet up and like train
depending on like what tournaments I'm
always so interested how people that are
really young get crazy passionate about
stuff was it something that was just in
you or your parents like pushed you or
uh I think originally for for martial
arts I was I got bullied a little bit
when I was younger and I was super quiet
didn't talk or anything so so like I
didn't like all the yelling at first and
then I came back like a few years later
yeah yeah I didn't like anything between
the student Creed you like yelling I'll
be like like just confused by the time
but but yeah I got into it after that
and then I I just fell in love like with
the technique because you know you're
just getting instructed and like doing
this I was like oh I can remember all
this stuff and then you know just that
self-confidence came from
um taking class and learning and getting
better and then I had really good
instructors too encouraging so that
helped a lot that to just solidify that
I really liked it because I kind of quit
all my other sports for martial arts did
you grow up here yeah um I grew up in
Thousand Oaks oh the valley yeah perfect
place for all that stuff though it's
like martial arts Central I know dang
uh first time I saw your stuff was like
I think you were doing nunchucks
really or or was it size or the uh it
was like this oh oh uh comments yeah
yeah yeah and you're doing flips and
kicks and stuff and I was like wow this
is like martial arts but like video game
martial arts I don't even know what the
hell it was because I done martial arts
but like I don't I'm like when are they
gonna teach me this [__] yeah what level
is that hey Steve can I see a really
personal question on camera what's up
how many how many times have you
um competed to the Mortal Kombat theme
song
competed zero but I'm definitely demos
you never you never use it oh no yeah
that was like everybody did generation
I've done demos with the Mortal Kombat
song oh for sure yeah bro I bet you guys
for sure you go often yeah because hey
play some right now dude
can I show you guys one of the things
that I first saw man yeah yeah yeah oh
yeah hell yeah I did oh [__] yeah yes
Memoirs of a Geisha you're in it
kitchen eyes
that's my first you must have been like
19 or something or whatever yeah yeah I
was I think it was yeah like 19 right or
whatever
freaking three ninjas which one the mega
Mountain one no no uh doing back I know
but I didn't do anything you're in three
ninjas in a baseball scene when they're
doing all that I bought a hot dog bro
what a hot dog I mean it was a big hot
dog is that is that the one with Hulk
Hogan no no I did kick back so the
second one not the wait the one in Japan
yeah yeah it's the best one
yeah but yeah so were you in Japan in
Japan nah it was the first part of the
movie where it's still in the valley
[Laughter]